W"WH THE  *
W"WATTHE  *
W"WATTEE  *
W"WATTERS *
W"WATTERS'*
W"WATTERS' WORLD" STARTS RIGHT
NOW.
JESSE: A TALE OF TWO TOURS.
BEFORE BARACK OBAMA WAS ELECTED
PRESIDENT HE FLEW TO EUROPE AND
THE SOCIALIST CROWDS LOVED HIM.
HE SAID THIS.
A CITIZEN.
A PROUD CITIZEN OF THE UNITED
STATES AND A FELLOW CITIZEN OF
THE WORLD.
JESSE: YOU PROBABLY REMEMBER
AFTER HIS ELECTION HE EMBARKED
ON THE APOLOGY TOUR.
>> IN AMERICA THERE IS A FAILURE
TO APPRECIATE EUROPE'S LEADING
ROLE IN THE WORLD.
DISMISSIVE AND DER
DISMISSIVE AND -ER
DISMISSIVE AND --R
DISMISSIVE AND -- AND DER
HAS SHOWN ARROGANCE AND BEEN
DISMISSIVE AND -- AND DERISIVE.
JESSE: THE MEDIA ATE THIS UP.
OBAMA'S FOREIGN POLICY WAS A
DISASTER, THE VOTERS REJECTED
LEADING FROM BEHIND.
ENTER DONALD TRUMP.
HERE HE IS IN EUROPE ON HIS
AMERICA FIRST TOUR URGING NATO
TO PAY THEIR BILLS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: MANY COUNTRIES
ARE NOT BUYING THEY SHOULD AND
THEY OWE US A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT
COUNTRIES AND THEY MAKE A FIVE
LINE DEAL WITH RUSSIA WHERE THEY
PUT BILLIONS OF DOLLARS INTO THE
COFFERS OF RUSSIA.
WE ARE SUPPOSED TO PROTECT YOU
FROM RUSSIA BUT YOU ARE PUTTING
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS INTO RUSSIA.
GERMANY WILL HAVE 70% OF THEIR
COUNTRY CONTROLLED BY RUSSIA
1%.
AMERICA IN ACTUAL NUMBERS IS
PAYING 4.2%, AND I THINK THAT'S
ANYTHING ABOUT IT BECAUSE I
DON'T THINK THEY UNDERSTOOD IT
OR THEY DIDN'T WANT TO GET
INVOLVES.
JESSE: TRUMP WANTS GERMANY
BUYING ENERGY WHY AMERICA, NOT
RUSSIA.
>> THE PRESIDENT DEPLOYING I
KNOW YOU ARE, BUT WHAT AM I.
INFLAMMATORY LANGUAGE I CAN
IMAGINE.
ANOTHER ONLY BEEN FISH AIRY OF
TRUMP TEMPERATURES HAVOC IS
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
JESSE: I REMEMBER WHEN ASKING
WEALTHY PEOPLE TO PAY THEIR FAIR
EVERYONE TO PAY THEIR FAIR
SHARE.
PAY THEIR FAIR SHARE.
JESSE: TRUMP IS TRYING TO
STRENGTHEN NADINE PEEL GERMANY
REMEMBER HE WAS CAUGHT TAPPING
ANGELA MERKEL'S CELL PHONE.
HE WAS CAUGHT TRASHING
NETANYAHU.
HE LEFT IRAQ TO ISIS AND IRAN.
FROM INVADING UKRAINE.
AND AFTER ALL THE FAKE NEWS
CHAOS HE MADE THIS ANNOUNCEMENT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: IT WAS A
PRODUCT IDEA SUMMIT WHERE MY JOB
PRIORITY WAS GETTING OTHER NATO
MEMBERS TO PAY THEIR FAIR SHARE.
WE HAVE GOTTEN COMMITMENTS FROM
THEM TO PAY FEAR THEIR DEFENSE